buenas tardes
como ustedes saben estamos viviendo en
nuestro país momentos importantes
momentos convulsos y me gustaría que en
estos 15 18 minutos que me han prestado
ojalá podamos pensar un poco afuera de
la caja podamos reflexionar sobre el
presente y sobre el futuro
y que estemos conscientes qué
[Música]
lo que creemos que va a pasar está
pasando hoy
es probable que alguna de las láminas ya
las conozcan pero creo que vale la pena
si me permiten como ustedes saben y
seguramente muchos de ustedes ya lo
conozcan
y amazon
si bien es cierto y me pueden decir oye
no ya tiene tiendas si compro world food
en eeuu y empieza a poner algunas
tiendas físicas pero amazon como ustedes
saben es el mayor vendedor de productos
al consumo
y hasta hace algunos años prácticamente
no tenía una sola tienda física
como dato interesante amazon su valor de
capitalización su valor en el mercado es
de 750 mil dólares mientras que el valor
de walmart es de solamente 250 mil
millones de dólares
como ustedes saben netflix ofrece
películas y saben cuántas salas de cines
tienen netflix
ninguna
a ver seguramente también ya lo saben es
el mayor
e innovador en temas de transporte y de
taxis y no tiene en sus activos
solo taxi spotify
spotify veo gente muy joven esta tarde
spotify no tiene un disco en su
inventario y es la herramienta que hoy
más la plataforma que más se utiliza el
día de hoy para escuchar música en vivo
es el hotel que vende más cuartos en el
mundo y no tiene un solo inventario de
cuarto en sus activos esa es la realidad
que estamos viviendo no el día de mañana
buen día de cinco años eso es hoy el
tema disruptivo que estamos viendo y me
gustaría que a partir de esta idea ojalá
podamos pensar como estudiantes como
empresarios en términos de la capacidad
a esta gente
perdimos un poco el hilo pero como ven
cuáles creen que son los países que
observan menor desarrollo en nuestro
país desafortunadamente los países del
sureste guerrero oaxaca chiapas y por lo
tanto como ven hacia el norte
empezando por el centro y en particular
querétaro tienen mayor nivel de
desarrollo que tiene que ver entre otras
cosas con la conectividad
por supuesto que el tema de la
interconexión siempre la discusión
si las redes sociales nos van a acercar
o nos van a alejar
y ahí existe
a mí es un tema que siempre me ha
interesado y lo he tratado estudiar
las redes sociales nos acerca porque nos
da la posible de conocer gente de todo
el mundo tener información en tiempo
real pero ha sucedido un fenómeno muy
particular
con el tema de las redes sociales hemos
bancarizado la capacidad de información
es decir hoy la gente que se mete a las
redes sociales lo más probable es que
busquen lo que les interesa busquen
aquellos temas que son de su interés y
no necesariamente han generado los
mejores las mejores herramientas de
comunicación entre las personas
una cosa que creo que vale la pena
mencionar en este contexto es
estamos en un momento pues electoral en
nuestro país y los políticos el ejército
los factores de poder piensan que son
los verdaderos dueños del poder actual y
ustedes saben quiénes son los verdaderos
dueños del poder
que creo que son los dueños de la
información
las redes sociales
las redes sociales tienen la capacidad
de conocer y hablaremos un poco más
adelante de ello tiene la capacidad de
conocer sus hábitos de consumo
tiene la capacidad de saber
que hacen que les gusta que les disgusta
que compran a qué hora que consultan y
hoy estas plataformas de redes sociales
son los que han acumulado un gran acervo
de conocimiento y de información y
ustedes saben que la información que es
poder
por lo tanto
los grandes
ganadores
hoy serán las redes sociales no sé si
ustedes sepan pero hace algunas semanas
el señor zuckerberg de facebook tuvo que
ir al congreso de los eeuu a explicar
por qué dio información de 50 millones
de usuarios de facebook de cara a las
elecciones
testificó se auto acusó pero hace dos
días en facebook reportó utilidades por
5 mil millones de dólares y su acción
subió ese día 9% nos guste o no nos
guste la tendencia de las redes sociales
y de la tecnología llegó y llegó para
quedarse y no hay forma de pararla
por supuesto que también en las redes
sociales a través de sus diferentes
componentes no serán un elemento toral
en la forma en la que ustedes se
comunican en la forma de que ustedes
interactúen con los demás y esta
información
siempre será conocida por diferentes
motores de información como puede ser
facebook twitter linkedin y todas
aquellas motores que ustedes conozcan en
términos de información
cuál es el riesgo que va a generar esta
revolución tecnológica
y se los comento porque ya lo hemos
empezado a ver y en este caso pues yo me
siento particularmente aludido
esta era digital
estamos seguros que va a traer una
consecuencia muy importante para las
sociedades y tendrán que haber políticas
públicas que resuelvan este problema
les comento rápidamente un par de datos
alguien ha ido a hablar de watson
aquella plataforma de ibm que puede
prácticamente leer y que tiene
inteligencia artificial
watson de ibm ya tiene capacidades para
a través del iris
y poder identificar y hacer análisis
clínicos para identificar cuáles son las
patologías que tienen cada uno de
ustedes entonces una de las cosas que es
muy probable que suceda es que
los médicos sobre sobre todo los médicos
internistas que hacen pruebas en el
cercano futuro queden desempleados otros
que quedarán desempleados serán gentes
como su servidor donde
hoy hay robots algoritmos que hacen
inversiones en tiempo milimétrico y
hacen a locación de activos cada segundo
en función de las tendencias del mercado
es decir no hay un equipo humano
suficiente para poder sustituir una
máquina que haga la locación de activos
esto es lo que va a traer entre muchas
otras áreas es un nivel de desempleo que
se puede comparar a lo que vivimos en la
crisis del 39 en la gran depresión
piense lo que esto significa para los
gobiernos
ustedes creo que nosotros no estamos hoy
conscientes del nivel de desempleo que
la robótica la era digital
va a generar y esto tendrá un efecto muy
importante para los países y creo que
volveremos a ver dentro de unos años lo
que pasó en los eeuu en la época de la
depresión de la gran depresión
desafortunadamente las sucursales
bancarias nosotros hoy seguimos
querétaro muy agradecidos abriendo
sucursales estos serán los nuevos bancos
del futuro
y el que no vea eso con claridad creo
que no está entendiendo lo que está
pasando en el mundo por supuesto que él
fintech necesito saber lo que esfínter
pero son todos aquellos desarrollos que
intentan estar fuera del sistema
financiero regulado en eeuu silicon
valley el año pasado recibió más de 20
mil millones de dólares de inversión de
fondos de capital de riesgo para hacer
apuestas en términos de fintech para
empresas que pasen que eso que que va a
ser el sistema financiero
como dato curioso para que ustedes sepan
en eeuu en los 50 estados o 51 si
quieren contar puerto rico- el 29 por
ciento de la población se dedica a
manejar un taxi
imagínense ustedes cuando google
el señor mos su ubicación mosca cuando
te es la o google
entiendo sí sé que hace poco
un coche de tesla fallo pero ojo no los
coches sin conductor van a estar en
funcionamiento en los próximos años no
se equivoquen en eeuu
29 estados de las 50 entidades en los
eeuu son taxistas imagínense su nivel
económico su nivel de educación qué va a
pasar con ellos en términos de desempleo
y quizás para hacer algunos de márquez
finales hay dos grandes vertientes
zuckerberg de facebook que piensa que la
inteligencia artificial es el futuro hoy
el robot guárdame en la caja que yo no
quiero hacer esto este as por favor en
el asiento contable el cargo y el abono
y hay otros como
el ser vos que piensan que la robótica
va a hacer al superhombre
y el superhombre estará la destrucción
del ser humano como ha sucedido en otras
civilizaciones y webó
la pregunta es existe la capacidad para
crear robótica con sentimientos que
puedan estar por encima de solo las
instrucciones del ser humano y volverse
en un tema auto destructivo
este niño que era yo de chiquito no es
cierto este niño
hace esa cara de sorpresa
que la biogenética la genética la
capacidad
de afectar los genes y hasta a la mano
de los ciudadanos que pasa por
cuestiones de carácter que hoy a lo
mejor no es el tema de discusión pero
este niño
hace esa cara de sorpresa
porque resulta
que sus padres son afroamericanos y los
hombres son sus padres biológicos los
son sus padres adoptivos
y ya tenemos la capacidad
de alterar como hemos visto en algunas
industrias de alimentarias ya son
capaces de alterar la biogenética de los
seres humanos y también somos capaces de
alterar la biogenética de los alimentos
entonces eso significa que amar a
personas que tengan recursos que quieran
que sus hijos sean rubios de ojos azules
y con el aic y más más alto que haya y
entonces eso significa que aquellos
niños que no tengan capacidades
económicas tendrán que salir con lo que
dios les dio entender y tendrán que
competir con aquellos súper hombres y
entonces les preguntaría si aquellos
niños que no tienen recursos serán niños
que podrán subsistir en la era digital
les sugiero que lean este libro que se
llama big data new data en war de
internet que te los aparts julio william
que lo que nos quiere decir es que
nosotros tenemos una capacidad
irnos auto mentirnos mentirle a nuestro
psiquiatra pero el único momento donde
sabemos quiénes somos es en la intimidad
cuando buscamos cualquier tipo de
información en cualquier motor social y
esto lo que nos dice es cuidado con lo
que buscan porque hay alguien del otro
lado que está revisando y saben lo que
están buscando y esto inclusive ha
generado problemas de tipo de vida del
punto de vista social hasta la
posibilidad de ganar elecciones
en los eeuu en países industrializados
la pregunta que yo les quisiera dejar y
que no tengo la respuesta es
nuestro país
nuestro querido méxico en nuestra época
compulsa en esta época tan complicada
que tenemos hacia adelante está
preparada para generar dos grandes
mexico´s o podemos cerrar la brecha
queremos un méxico marginado un méxico
que no tenga acceso a la tecnología que
no tenga acceso al mundo digital que no
tengo acceso al conocimiento o un méxico
que ya se está separando como el que
vivimos en este estado que está que vive
en el desarrollo que vive con conceptos
de calidad educativa que está en la era
digital
la pregunta que les quiero dejar y que
quiero que razone en esta noche es cómo
podemos ir cerrando la brecha entre
estos dos grandes mundos que vivimos la
era digital de la gente desarrollada que
captura todo el valor económico y
aquellos que no tienen acceso a nada a
muy poco muchas gracias les agradezco
mucho espero que les haya servido
[Aplausos]